[Music]
what is the eu's role in the world
how should it deal with migration
these were just two of the questions
asked at the conference on the future of
europe's fourth citizens panel there is
no going back through the conference we
are deepening european political culture
from the very roots up 200 eu citizens
took part at parliament's home in
strasbourg debates and group discussions
focused on european defense capabilities
eu enlargement trade and relations with
other world powers
they also discussed eu border management
civil protection development aid and
international cooperation
migration proved to be a hot topic
discussions included how to encourage
solidarity between eu countries and
europe's asylum policies i feel like we
should not close our borders more but we
should open and give more possibilities
for migration and for us to integrate
with each other
i'm happy if we help refugees but
i think integrating millions of
immigrants that's a big issue next month
the four citizens panels will continue
their conversations online
a final round of deliberations will be
held in the european cities of
maastricht dublin warsaw and florence
representatives selected from each panel
will help shape the conference's
recommendations in spring 2022